welcome to this video this is Round
three coverage of the gushy moth
Memorial Tournament currently held in
Azerbaijan in sham Kia yeah round three
this was a far more interesting round
then the road before am yeah wrong
before we had four drawers and just one
win this time it was a bit more
interesting however not all of the games
were exciting and I'm going to focus on
the three most interesting games and
really really quickly talk about two
games that weren't so interesting let's
start with that one Mahmoud off with
white against kramnik ya Mahmud off
being a little bit of a dark horse in
this tournament let's say some the
father lowest-rated of the participants
but he has the number three player of
them the home country so he's some he's
there to to prove that his yeah kind of
guy can can be long belong there fight
fight on equal grounds with the top guys
he played very solidly the first two
rounds and we see here against Kramnik
we've got the rip he always plays eform
Mahmoud of dust and chronic plays the
Berlin you have to us I hoped that he
would do something a little bit more
ambitious let's say because the Berlin
has some well some lines that really
don't yeah offers so much in terms of
winning potential and mummy dog place
this line the rookie one line where the
play very often gets simplified a lot
yeah we see that him the e-file is open
Black has to block them yeah and we get
this kind of position and this is the
typical power structure arising from the
rookie one line on five and yeah people
who play the French will probably see
something familiar here we have the open
e file it's just like the exchange line
in the French and here in this
particular case
there's even nights traded Kevin so Jack
and have a look at that that's really
really equal black has no problem here
whatsoever but he also doesn't have any
winning chances the whole game was
basically on a trade of many pieces we
had the heavy piece is traded on the
e-file and well chromic tried to do a
little bit there with queenie aid but
there's really nothing going on white
can just stay and um yeah we had to
Queen trade and after be 5 p.m. black
went to Bishop d7 and in this structure
why does some get like fraction fraction
more active looking but better looking
because of the slightly better pawn
structure but and there is simply not
much happening and he went over to be
for now here and here they agree to a
draw it is a draw in whatever way maybe
black can trade he can move the bishop
away doesn't really matter yeah this
this looks a little bit sick yeah with
black sitting there on the on the wrong
color complex but it's just so close
there's nothing going to happen here
it's a complete complete draw and the
second game that wasn't so interesting
was Mammadyarov vashi de Graaff the only
slightly interesting point actually is
this position what move three where
mummy dro went Bishop to g5 a very
unusual move really which looks like a
mix of the Trump our ski jump off scheme
and and the classical d4c for opening um
but there wasn't anything
happening or something nothing unique
came out of it this is what I wanted to
say as Bishop g7 93 d5 just post in to
gruene felt anyway a funny funny green
fat though we're black after takes takes
takes is a pawn down and even two points
after c5 names here white can take a
second point if he likes the black has
very nice compensation here with with
moves like Queen 85 or sometimes 9 a-6
is an option you very often get at least
the c5 pawn back and then black is
playing with this fantastic bishop there
on g7 something similar happened in the
game yeah like took and with Queen B 6
castles rock d8 we see that black is
getting active quickly the bishop is
strong and e6 will put pressure on the
d5 pawn rook c1 e 6 we should be 296
castles very very natural logical moves
yeah now um black as some where she is
just capturing on c3 with a
simplification yeah it doesn't look like
a move you want to play but you want to
get your pawn back at some point and
with this move you do take stakes in our
pawn takes that is to push deform
opening up the position and if white is
not careful he might even cut out
slightly worse out of that because at
the end after d4 very often the black
pieces will be more active than whites
pieces he went roxy five-year attacking
the the pole and now a six yeah
interesting continuation black was some
probably not so keen on seeing this on
the board it's nothing great for white
but it's something that you if you can
prevent that you like to do that
therefore a6 that Quincy one was played
what about rook t5 was that a
possibility yes but after Bishop e6
black it's very very active now after
rook takes rook takes where's the Queen
going is all
so the bishop having influence on that
so like here and here black has choices
you can take on b3 what can play night
before and you will win a pawn back in
both cases yeah it went Quincy one bit
should be 694 wide really blocking the
pawn and TM you see it's a very very
symmetrical position and they're really
didn't happen much afterwards we had
some trades down ya later here jack
there was a petrol check Queen B 825
check so not the most exciting game ever
um only little remarkable thing the kind
of funny opening move order that
mamedyarov went for um yeah there are
yeah this is motivated by the desire to
vie avoid the pure gruene felt or at
least steer black into something that he
may be does not want to have like this
particular greenford line but it didn't
prove to be a problem but she was in no
problem in nowhere trouble whatsoever
the whole game so these were the queue
less than exciting games let's now go to
the more interesting ones we had vishy
anand playing white against onigiri and
after a four yeah again are not going be
for naught D for as he did in most
recent tournaments Giri went c6 maybe we
she was looking forward for a duel in
the sicilian um giri has a soft spot for
some Sicilian lines that maybe yeah
maybe not bad but bit dicey but it
didn't happen he went c6 so the CARICOM
defense and e5 was played the advance
yeah analyst mixing it he plays the
advance which is nowadays arguably the
main move but he also plays Knight c3
and enters this classical lines good 'if
I've Bishop f5 93 e 6 or normal we have
the short system with
be 292 here a very interesting moment an
afternoon I'd be three here black has a
has a choice he has a more old-fashioned
ways let's say to play um this means a
move like night c8 for example yeah
where Bishop e7 is coming the night
maybe to be 6 and at one moment c5
there's also modern way to play it and
this is the move g5 not the move or not
a move that would that comes very
naturally or would have come very
naturally to players let's say in the
1970s or 1980s where this would have
been viewed as very odd rageous to move
the jeep on but nowadays this is so
commonplace that the Jeep aunt is used
on in the opening early on that though
we may not really irritated anymore by
it yeah black gained some space on the
kingside he gains this square for
example that is now located behind the
pawn chain and he also make sure that
yeah he he knows where to put the bishop
sometimes bishop on g 7 f-6 those kind
of ideas I in the position it term it
again it gets very interesting now nitey
one Queen c7 Bishop h5 this is a new
move actually yeah Bishop h5 that has
not been played before at least
according to my database f-4s been
played before me and we look that didn't
make a note on that yes f4 it was played
by nakamura against em shankland hear
this f4 in the recently-concluded US
Championships with smooth just make a
lot of sense it looks at the pollen f7
and at least make sure that black is not
cancelling long easily okay c5 why not
attacking the center c3 Bishop g7 f4c
for a surprise I was a bit surprised
that black is some freezing the center
you will see for
at least um yeah you have an idea where
to put your king I thought long castles
would still be on the agenda but in fact
we see that after this and this the idea
was far more concrete this pawn is now
something that white has to has to get
back and it's not so easy to do if you
take it with the rook black cancelled
short and plays f6f 6 you know black is
better developed why it is somewhat
somewhat behind him on the queenside f6
will hit black skin looks insecure but
you are very very quick there with your
with your plane Island played
differently played Knight to f3 96
covering F for the capture and night eh
was so very concrete play by the former
world champion castles and now black a
threatening g5 made simply keeping the
pawn rook f/4g five first of all you
might think okay as wish you blundered
no we didn't night f5 is a move g takes
97 King g7 this is an exchange sacrifice
so very interesting early in valencia
change reforms coming king 2h7 Queenie 6
wise white got a big palm there the e6
pawn backbone here of blacks pawn chain
white would be in really nice shape if
all of his pieces would play at the
moment those two are not really
participating much the 91 and the bishop
on c1 yeah I don't try to get them into
play we see that Queen back to 83
commune of seven g3 yeah really saying
okay I want to get rid of this pawn my
bishop has to play white looks funny I
really I did the live broadcast today
for the ICC together with Grandmaster
Tomo garea very enjoyable experience I
was the host and timo was mostly doing
the analysis was always a good way to
spend the day
listening to a very competent
Grandmaster analyzing and giving the odd
idea here and there that he knows
refuted or sometimes my ideas were okay
yeah III was an idea that I had tried to
break and break up the Kings side and
get the bishop into play it is
interesting black black could not take
off course and we have Chatwin here I
mean it's not like it's losing but it
doesn't look too great to allow that
Queen g6 and 92 yeah note that white
couldn't take simply here because there
was a pin down 92 and now black talk
pawn takes rook f3 this route gets
activated Bishop here Queen H form and
rookie won this kind of position White
has a pawn for the exchange he has the
strong passer de pawn and it's not so
clear what this night is doing black
however has its problems this rope here
is on a three-test no square it might be
trapped yeah i'm just an attack by the
night and it would only have d3 to go to
we see something like that happening
Queen to e6 played by Giri Queen h5 rook
to e3 Bishop e3 white Anand is clearing
the f4 square for the night he wants to
trap the rook but giri has a nice
defense he went 97 putting this night on
a better square and getting it back into
the game remember the night on b6 didn't
have anywhere to go and now he has
initiated this activation however
neither for what it says this is just a
fork it isn't theirs Queen g8 that's
strong it @ XG 3 verse check and
therefore technically basic technically
continues continues the game yeah what
what about why it's options now he can
take the rook this is what happened in
the game this you have anything else
it's difficult actually g3 is hanging if
you cover it there's nine f5 all of a
sudden intensifying the pressure there
it's not so easy how
how does this this unfold if Y
discovering this now black is able to
trade you can also take care of the rook
let's say is this kind of position and
situation is not clear Queen f7 let's
say yeah II six-win f5 note that black
has count to play in various ways it's
not really a huge winning try if white
is going for King age too he decided to
take it on d3 and it turns out that this
pretty much almost pretty much by force
leads to a draw there is a check on g3
and the move Knight to f5 very strong
move actually it's the only move
therefore not that difficult to find but
it's it's very effective me as strongest
maybe the wrong the wrong phrase
implying that it is difficult to see but
it's a very very effective move this
night is attacking the bishop queen is
looking at the night porn is attacking
the knight and if the night moves jack
oops there's a big rookie only one so
it's very tricky for white to move the
pieces he has to return one of the
pieces he went for Bishop f4 queen d 3 &
e6 initiating counterplay there with the
pawn yeah and this is it turns out
really am almost four strong 97 that's a
good move black is giving up this pawn
just kind of funky but it has an idea he
controls the age 5 square now and this
way also f3 so Queen f3 check is now in
the in the position and this is the
motif that will ultimately yeah end the
game with a drawn we will see kingi to
check and queen f5 going for Queen g4
yeah let's have a look that sorry that
that is the only move from sorry I had
another idea but stuff that wasn't
working at all yeah e 7 this is what
happened what was playing ass trump card
the pawn and now black jack is able to
force a draw with the shake this is what
happened King edge black weiner 3 and
here they agree to a draw you can just
repeat the position like that or another
way to draw as king age two and drag now
can check go for this rook and jam him
which is also a complete draw there's
nothing much to play for so an
interesting game between Vicki Allen and
arnesh Geary with them yeah a good fight
a good fight really where maybe there
was in the complication there I'm not
totally sure I concentrated and also in
the broadcast we concentrated them a lot
on the game by Mongoose cards and we'll
see that later so we couldn't really we
didn't find something great there for
white maybe white had something around
around these these times here but it
wasn't something very obvious if there
if there was something okay let's have a
look at the next game we look now at the
two one of the two leaders in Wesley's
so Micky Adams Micky Adams has lost his
first round game then played a draw and
Wesley so one is first round game
against tarnish Geary so so so it's a
one of the co-leaders of the event let's
see what we had we had a Queens gambit
declined now the classical move order
with the nine on f6 this is a move order
that was very much out of fashion for a
long long time due to the exchange
variation yeah the CD ed also known as
the cards but um this the reason why
Adam was believed to be a bit
uncomfortable blankets that in former
times black mostly played the main line
this means this there should be seven
castles and queens 2nite here now White
has a convenient choice between 922 or
h3 and Knight f3 those kind of ideas it
always a little bit
better for what it really is and quite
passive sometimes for black a position
that I played quite often with the white
pieces however there's a new idea or an
idea that it's not new but was some yeah
kind of was shown that on there is an
idea for black that was a bit unjustly
ignored let's say or underestimated the
idea is that if we look at this black
head plate age six only here if I plays
a normal movie let's say Quincy two
blankets playing nine age five this idea
is as I said already it's not not new
but it was maybe underestimated for a
very long time this trade is helping
black get the Queen to e7 and black has
good chances to get his King on the
queenside night to be six Bishop e6 long
castles this is how it is played quite
often and there have been a number of
top-level games and we saw crumb neg on
the black side we saw cards and on the
black silent wasn't much happening there
I mean black seemed to be quite ok and
well what is best is so doing he plays
the move f3 interesting move and he took
about six minutes for that maybe he was
really coming up with that over the
board it is very often the case that you
think that everything is prepared
beforehand and they have it all figured
out and so on but well sometimes some
interesting concepts are really
developed over the board she remember
West lays game from round one way he
went king f1 early in the opening he
took 20-something millions for that and
that was also an innovation over the
board and it turned out to be very
successful what is their idea of f3 it
controls fo and g4 this is the typical
thing that f3 does and it is directed
against this idea what is not taking now
but retreating the bishop retreating
does not mean passivity when white is
doing is he keeps pieces on the board
and says that ok I'm going to play e4 in
the future not right away it will take a
while but then i'll have more
phase and I rather have more pieces on
the board with a space advantage very
typical you don't want to trade if you
have more space here why does not have
more space yet but he has them the
perspective to get it with the form so
keeping pieces on the board makes sense
also it makes the night on h5 look at
Ted sunny here probably has to go back
rather rather quickly yeah castles was
played so Adams is just saying okay I
understand no night age five today but
there are other ideas here three is an
early commitment Quincy to and now Adams
came up with a very interesting concept
b5 not a move you see every day in the
in the card spot structure but it is
quite interesting the ideas that it
grabs space and it gives this additional
idea Knight b6 and night see for the c-4
night is then nicely supported by the
pawn I think that this was a very um
correctly or let's say a very um it was
a game played with with with much logic
in it yet was very understandable what
was happened Bishop d7 blank is going
now for Knight to c4 God Bishop to e6
and now 97 again trying to trade which
was declined white kept everything on
the board yeah so what are the ideas
white might push Aoife at one point he
might have f4 at some point fyf five the
central breaks and black is looking to
use his active PS on c4 maybe play at
the right moment b5 sorry b5 before or
c65 yam them the timing is very crucial
here Ruby c 8 t 1 Queen c7 and h3 yeah a
kind of an innocent-looking move what is
83 doing the idea we see here fo all of
a sudden not efore but f-for idea being
that f4 f5 is trapping the bishop so
black has to worry about that he has to
react to that and he did so with a 4
with the counter
checking move and yeah now Wesley so
took this opportunity to transform to
change the position by playing at five
it's a funny way to trade pieces takes
on b3 and black took there so we have
equal material still but a funny trade
their of the light squared Bishop father
for the night down be three rock p8
Quincy to and before yeah breaking up
breaking open the B file who's better in
this position it's not easy to say what
has the bishop and you guys know that I
like the bishops but black has a sound
structure he doesn't have a bad piece he
has a good healthy pawn structure with
to pawn islands I think we are talking
about him an approximately equal
position however this move Queen 85 was
a bit tricky it was something that it
looks like an innocent move yeah but it
has a drawback bishop edge form now
played by so this is certainly something
that maybe i don't know maybe adams
underestimated this move i'm not sure
but it is a bit awkward to face yeah you
don't want to play g5 which can lead to
a big trouble the King side is terribly
weak and there are even some some
tactical ideas like rook f1 this is
given by the computer not a very natural
move but it is interesting after taking
there should be six is killing black
really killing Queen g6 with a mate to
come yeah something like that it's just
mate yeah g5 you don't want to do that
but this looks terrible as well yeah you
don't want that to happen again Queen g6
there should be six is a fancy muha but
you can also go look at one or something
why the tech is just wrong this is a
very very damaged bone structure not
sure though maybe bit should be six is
good I was thinking black can just move
the king but maybe what can just take to
be honest you know this is very
dangerous
and now lucky for something not super
dangerous yeah but what do you want to
play again special age for you have to
play f6 what Adams did but this is not a
move you really like to play with the
light squared weaknesses coming up here
it's not easy to play now I ever Wesley
so he didn't take a take an opportunity
he could play 94 now an interesting move
based on the fact that she falls on pre
after the capture this is a big mistake
of course takes and why does just um
well just be winning him basically i'm
getting a pawn and keeping all attacking
prospects 94 was very dangerous but he
didn't play it goodnight a for keeping
an eye on b2 and so on 9 f8 Bishop d3
ip6 back to c 3 c 5 yeah black is
opening up the position trying to get to
the e3 porn at the end oh this is some
still in the range of equal slightly
better for wine maybe but not much but
we have a very critical situation coming
up King edge 1 rook c8 Bishop f5 this is
a critical position and in fact the
moment where Adams is making a very
decisive misstep the rook is hanging on
see 80 of course he has to do something
with it and it seems he should play
rugby eight maybe rook aaj 11 of those
two moves he went to see 611 and this is
um yeah this is a move that it looks a
bit more active than new piedra crooked
but it has a big drawback the rukon d8
now is unprotected it's sitting in the d
file and in this diagonal and this is
really a big big issue right now went
be4 and what now and while you're
threatening at the moment to take on d5
just winning upon black cannot take it
if he advances there's 'if I've
and the five is the big problem anyway
using this pin on the diagonal age 42 d
8 when white will take on f6 blacks pawn
structure is going to get get completely
smashed I really don't see how black
should defend him it seems completely
lost d 4 it's not not possible at all he
went to be for them the with the bishop
and now we're 5s mansion this is the
idea blacks pawn shelter I have in front
of the king is getting getting them
destroyed Bishop here queen bee three
looking at this diagonal right black
cakes here and this is just hanging
Quincy five was played but that ran into
this issue however black some defensive
task was probably um yeah it was
probably something that is not
manageable simply whites play is too
strong them Quincy for and after the
capture we see now how bad blacks King
position is after nice check and you
went here yeah you cannot go to AJ this
is leading to a very quick end of the
game but Queen King to f7 after rookie
one isn't much of a difference Luke is
seven mate yeah and to me this mate is
made and pretty dangerous there's
nothing to do really black went Queen to
b4 check rookie seven yeah rookie seven
is a simple way to do it the white queen
is starting this invasion now and like
went here yeah going to d6 check it's
not helping you lose the house so oops
back here and now blacks king is out of
squares just one check and that's it and
here's the check Bishop g4 to age five
and that's it yeah a very nice game by
West day so ultimately in the time
scramble Adam
some fell apart time scramble is a bit
strong they had like five minutes but
yeah if we go back there I'm sorry that
was far too many moose I'm talking about
this moment here where Luke c6 was
played here at about five minutes note
that they don't play with increment in
this tournament so it was just pure five
minutes 47 moves not a huge time trouble
but yeah it was certainly played a role
with more time when the clock else would
probably see that this is putting his
his pieces in bets in bad spots
especially the unprotected rook there
which allows this you fall push you know
however I think that allowing this in
the first place that those light squares
are so weak was also tricky because it
makes it pie it's up a little bit yeah
it was a relatively if we go back there
just for a moment here before Queen a
fight happened here black has a position
that is pretty much without any
weaknesses it looks very nice and solid
and you don't really want to play of six
which was all over some necessary after
Bishop h4 just f6 is a square where you
want the night to sit on maybe a bishop
or so what you don't want to pawn them
with all the light square so weakened
this is maybe something that the
computer is not yeah being irritated
about very much but human player is not
liking this kind of weak weaknesses that
were created okay so nice win there for
Wesley so who's leading the tournament
with two and a half points out of three
this is as much I can already say
because he was leading before the rounds
together with two other players so when
will keep him in the lead but what about
kawana Council Road number one against
world number two yeah number two on the
life list is Kara wanna and it's a very
close business though um Nakamura is
just like one point behind or something
it's all changing on a daily basis with
every game so what happened to you Kara
wanna Carlson d
for okay Kara wanna is of course able to
play in any opening like him the the top
players are almost them all of them are
very versatile in their first move um
but still he's more of an e4 player
recently and d4 a slight surprise what
is car isn't doing f5 great yeah we have
got a fight ya know let's say I'm not
saying it a bit boring defense and some
kind of my no Queens gambit leska
whatever we have a have a Dutch defense
interesting stuff what is it going to be
it is a stone wall with e6 the stone
wall is initiated and enter we can
really am compare this to the game
honored Carlton played in the
baden-baden tournament earlier in
February this year a very interesting
game there between anand and carlsen
ended in a win for the world champion in
that game we also had be three Queenie
seven but here on in this position on a
nun plate with Knight to e5 I just want
to show the first couple of moves
briefly to show you how it went after 90
to contemplate 85 an interesting idea a5
a4 he tries to utilize this rook on them
on the a file on the initial square
that's an interesting way to play this
position um an important point there to
understand is that this Bishop 1c8 is
not a great piece what are you going to
do with it you can play this kind of
maneuver this snake like activation or
you can put it on the can put it on the
b7 square you can fianchetto well how is
this related to a 5 with a 5 black stays
flexible you can even put the or can
even keep the bishop on c8 for a while
because if a 5 f4 activates the rook
there is no big need for this Bishop to
be moved you keep very flexible the a
poor move is a favorite of cards in this
Dutch structures he had also played it
in
in a Leningrad structure against Reuters
check in tata steel this year this
didn't turn out so well but in general
85 is one of his favorite ideas let's
have a look here p should be to be 695
we should be 792 castles rook c 105 here
we go again they pawned his favorite his
favorite idea why not yet yeah okay so
III was played in 96 yeah it seems that
karana wasn't really that much prepared
for this opening he spent lots of time
and to be perfectly honest I don't think
that he has got anything at all in this
position it it looks some very very okay
for black black hands or pieces into
play and you don't really see a great
direct idea for white um one idea that
is quite quite commonplace in them and
them in the stone body for white is to
put the Knights here one night on d 31 +
f3 here 93 or ever is answered by night
before double attacking yeah an
interesting idea with this with this a
pawn takes takes and all of a sudden the
a pawn is weak not be one was played
yeah not a very natural but it has an
idea what maybe wants to regroup the
night to a form let's a bad idea no I'm
I wanted to paint this pawn looking at
the pawn with the night coming to a form
that is probably the idea the second
idea might be under some circumstances
to be able to play Bishop a three we see
how this is as we see some of that in
the game because cars and takes and
therefore bishop a3 gets into the
picture yeah why did black take 1e5 an
interesting decision he gave up the
bishop there the d6 bishop that seems
like an important defender of the dark
squares true this is a dark squared
bishop and therefore important for the
dark squares but very important is that
if I
which was a weakness that might be
occupied at some point by a piece is now
blocked by a pawn the party five is far
less of a problem than a piece setting
only five so Black has solved this
problem of the e5 weakness he also has
put a knight on e4 quite a nice spot for
this piece not so easy for whites to
play this position when we were
broadcasting a garea my man Mike Oh
commentator and and main analyst in this
and this duo he had this suggestion yeah
something that I that I liked I'm sorry
we actually looked at this one move
later Queenie to a forum this was the
position f 395 Bishop e3 I think this is
a pretty decent idea for what trying to
activate this bishop and get it on a
diagonal where there's something
happening not just looking at the e5
pawn this was interesting or also Bishop
e3 before f3 both was an interesting
option here black whoever has to move c5
that's also a possibility where the
bishop here on the b7 auto son gets more
scope all this is a very this is complex
and interesting so it would have been an
interesting choice there Bishop e3
Caruana played differently he went 93
after that however it seems that black
doesn't have any kind of problem not
sure we would have had a problem in the
other the other line but here it is
clear that this is no big threat from
black this is the key idea Queen e7 to
be form like a text the b3 porn and asks
why it okay what are you going to do
about the queenside why took on your
form yeah it's not a great it's not a
move that yeah looks great but what are
you going to do if you can will be 3
like that black might even use this
night to attack the pawn and it seems
that this is very hard to defend
he took their and now the deep one
captured yeah that's a better move than
F takes after F takes bishop h3 is
giving what quite a bit of activity down
so taking with this pawn with the deep
on makes more sense now we have a funny
situation Bishop on g2 bishop on b7
who's got the better bishop yeah bishop
on g2 is also not looking looking very
very great but first of all what about
the pawn their own be three yeah White's
idea what's the following Quincy too
he's threatening bishops III now kicking
kicking everything back so Carlton went
95 attacking be three this is Pawn that
he's just winning for the moment Bishop
c3 takes takes takes was why just
blundering upon no he gets it back of
course rupee 195 rupee six along a
sequence that is now absolutely forced
night a phone has to be played rugby 793
this is pretty much happening by force
yeah if we go back five three or four or
five moves ago this is an almost forced
sequence rookie seven attacking the pawn
rook e8 interesting moment here kawana
is not keeping the rook on the board I
was surprised I thought rook c7 is
better here trying to keep the rogue
active yeah we have many ways now to
draw like this for example but he didn't
do it he went check with the trade
andrew k 1 and i think i read a tweet
and dis dis mentioned that Kara wanna
stated after the game that he thought
that um he could basically play anything
and and draw yeah let's see what
happened a rupee g8 bishop f1 c5 rugae
three here and I suggested in the
broadcaster move look c5 I think that
was an interesting alternative um it is
a tricky move though because rook to d2
and tonight's to d1 will be quite
complicated to assess you lose this part
but let's say xe8 check maybe here takes
check so I'm something like this then h3
yeah this seems to be perfectly okay for
white the night on f 2 has really
nowhere to go as h3 is keeping g4 out of
the picture the energy form both it
seems to make a rook c5 org a 5 to
attack this this position wasn't option
it seems he went drew a 3 though and now
night be one rook a 192 and now it gets
tricky Knight to f3 I think at this
point karana probably um yeah realized
that it's not going to be that easy
after Bishop e2 in fact Knight f3 takes
takes I believe that white is in very
substantial trouble if not I mean losing
is a bit much but I think he's in huge
trouble the problem is that this Bishop
Addison Bishop this pawn on f3 is a very
very strong factor in the position it
takes away those two crucial squares and
keeps the White King totally passive
what cannot use his rook in an active
way SS rookie one mate hitting yeah
let's say age three and age 5 g for that
was played but let's say why displaying
passively let's just try let's say H for
what is happening there Black is
invading rook t2 and how it's light
going to defend this now if you are
active let's say you try to act to
attack the pawn chechik and this is
going to happen do you want to give you
have to pawn you probably want what
about this looks you one okay how do you
defend this no you go here okay Brooksie
to King g1 our way to answer
but I am what about here yeah I'm just
asking you for move now King edge 3 is
made checkmate you cannot move any of
the pawns they are all completely
blocked and this rook has to move now
which means that you give away the pawn
like here and here here looks it too and
this is going to fall yeah like king
here check and black will win this pawn
and ultimately this point and ultimately
the game a very problematic rogaine game
that is probably lost to be honest I
think it's lost and Cara wanna try to
escape with g4 yeah a break out move
takes takes and now very important not
taking which gives this option and why
it is totally fine but H for getting the
past pawn down the past h pawn went here
I look T to King edge 3g 5 you have to
keep the pawn it's not good to take here
this is giving giving white huge
activity that's just the airport now and
it's much better to keep this pawn
protected f2a still attacked white ride
with a tricky defense he went before
here is the last really a crucial moment
let's say cards now has to avoid one
trap it's not difficult to what the oh
look f2 is a big mistake because of a
perpetual check now let's say chimecho
check it sir the crazy rook you have
white can check check check and it's a
stalemate yeah like this you know check
stalemate yeah the only only little
thing that Jay I found quite quite funny
is that in some cases here White has to
be a bit bit careful check he thinks he
can do it like he pleases and then she
this for example black is of course not
taking for the statement but just moving
King d7 and here oh I'm sorry check and
here wyd will notice that he has a pawns
that
the stain laid from being in effect so
you cannot check anymore you have to
continue now with a move like that which
after you gave one probably loose and
very short order like here here here
yeah so it's it's still a bit a bit
tricky but absolutely no problem to draw
if why this some circumspect them and
instead of Luke a 8 just always checks
on the seventh-ranked yeah this is of
course check check a complete easy draw
so Carlton was not able to take on f2
but it's not necessary you can also just
attack all those weaknesses check got a
couple of checks there one check two
p.m. again all the sea porn is deciding
plus there's still the H pawn in the
game look here up to 3m check white
covered f3 and now the C porn was
running Rupert e7 was also a good move
also here Eric t7 that was what was my
suggestion during the broadcast they all
win see 3 SC 2 i'm sorry rook c4 check
check and now King d7 yeah asking white
ok what are you going to do he went here
Luke f2 and now we see the dilemma their
white cannot cover with Roxy 3 even
because of 53 and the pawn is promoting
yeah this was played gee cakes I'm sorry
GTX would have one as well it you get he
gave this check and took on f4 yeah this
was the final move of the game Caruana
resigned so again win with the black
pieces by magnus carlsen against his one
of his main rivals nowadays fabiano
caruana heard of the stone wall dutch
very strategically focused opening i
think actually it was a very very good
opening choice by cards of course um
your hindsight is always twenty-twenty
but i think coronas main main strength
maybe maybe them the ability to
calculate in a very very precise way
and being very technically alert in
complicated positions then so more Dutch
is an opening that is very very
strategically focused where you cannot
really do much with with pure pure
calculation power let's say so not a bad
idea getting Carolina into the strategic
battle and a very nice of an instructive
endgame that shows how strong the corn
on f3 can be that limits here White's
King a very nice game I think by by
Carlton and the game that put him into
the to the cool eat together with Wesley
so yeah I hope you enjoy to the
curvature of round three of course I'll
be back tomorrow with round four yeah
hope you are watching that video as well
tomorrow thanks again and have a good
sunday if you watch it on the Sunday bye
bye